Естонія. Нарва. Зона дії російської культури та естонських законів.
З населенням у 60 тисяч це найбільша російськомовна громада ЄС.
Почути у місті естонську мову - це як виграти у лотерею, жартують місцеві.
Ті, хто вперше прибули з Таллінна, спочатку трохи шоковані.
Дивуюся, що тут усі всіх знають!
Та чого дивуватися, містечко наше - як село.
Багатьох жителів Нарви об'єднує ще один важливий момент - їм важливо,
щоб міст "Дружба" між Нарвою та Івангородом не переставав працювати.
Це стосується й молоді. Ярославна, наприклад, регулярно ходить через річку
в Івангород доглядати за літньою бабусею.
Як і багато мешканців Нарви, я періодично ходжу до Росії.
Щонайменше кілька разів на місяць. Тому що в мене в Івангороді живе бабуся.
Така досить типова, як на мене, історія не тільки для мешканців Нарви.
Але оскільки ми тут живемо так близько до кордону, то цілком нормально сходити
в місто до бабусі. У кращі часи, коли відносини з Росією були ліпшими,
було цілком нормально ввечері сходити з друзями, випити в бар, наприклад.
І потім повернутися до Нарви.
А от Володимиру Каштану цей міст більше не потрібен.
Хіба що як майданчик для своїх антивоєнних перформансів.
Художник із Нарви на момент російського вторгнення жив у Санкт-Петербурзі.
Але згодом був змушений виїхати звідти через побоювання бути заарештованим.
Я не міг спати, я бачив нескінченні хвилі ОМОНу, які пі**ть бабусь і дівчаток.
Я чекав обшуку. Ще до початку війни моїх знайомих активно забирали то вдома, то десь в метро.
Було питання: або я залишаюся і роблю щось реально гучне, що бомбане
і покаже, що в Росії є люди, які не згодні з тим, що відбувається.
Нас мало, нас пі**ть і садять.
Або я намагаюся таки зберегти себе і намагатися робити щось із-за кордону.
Враховуючи, що я маю естонське громадянство, я дійшов висновку,
що, напевно, краще зберегти себе. Це був складний вибір.
Каштан - громадянин Естонії. Він народився 1992 року, тому отримав
це громадянство автоматично. У Нарві це типовий випадок.
Частина містян живуть із "сірими" паспортами "негромадян",
як археологиня Ярославна Назарова.
Більша частина життя мого батька пройшла в Естонії.
І до того моменту, коли Естонія остаточно відокремилася, моя сім'я жила вже десь близько десятка років у Нарві.
Тоді всім здавалося, що закриття кордону буде більш-менш переборним.
І було вирішено залишитися жити у Нарві.
Саме тому, мені здається, мої батьки не взяли російське громадянство.
Тому вони отримали "сірі паспорти". І відповідно я теж отримала "сірий паспорт".
Ярославна та Вован репрезентують молоде проєвропейське покоління міста.
Тим часом люди з антизахідними поглядами рідко погоджуються
озвучувати їх на камеру, щоб уникнути проблем з владою Естонії.
Я вважаю, що Путін і фашистський російський режим паразитує на ресентименті.
І так, в Естонії є для цього певне підґрунтя.
Тому що дійсно, будемо відвертими, будуючи естонську демократію,
з цього процесу виключили більш ніж третину населення.
Це має юридичне обґрунтування, проте третина населення була відсторонена
від прийняття юридичних рішень.
Так, є підґрунтя для образи. І ворог у нинішній ситуації цим користується, це культивує.
Розкол у нарвській громаді стався ще 2014 року, на тлі анексії Криму
та російської війни на Донбасі. Вже тоді в Таллінні заговорили про загрозу
вторгнення в Нарву російських військ під виглядом захисту "руського міра".
Місцеві політики та соціологи, однак, до таких сценаріїв ставляться скептично.
Щодо Нарви та питання "чи буде Нарва next"? Ні.
Тут місцеві люди з 2014 року говорять журналістам, які приїжджають з усього світу,
що Нарва - це їхній дім, Естонія - це їхній дім. Так, російська культура для них перша.
Але Естонія є тим домом, де вони хочуть жити.
У серпні 2022 року в Нарві демонтували останній радянський меморіал
із танком Т-34 в Естонії як потенційне джерело напруги.
Поліції вдалося запобігти заворушенням, але рішення влади викликало
у багатьох невдоволення. Проблема з інтеграцією цих людей - це і наслідок політики Естонії.
У Росії організують пропагандистські акції, призначені для жителів Нарви.
В Івангороді до 9 травня збудували концертний майданчик спеціально
для аудиторії із сусідньої країни. "Свято побєдобісся", як називає це Вован.
Це велика різниця між тим, що заборонено в Росії, коли, не дай Боже,
ти вийдеш з плакатиком, тебе одразу ж заарештують, і в Естонії, де багато людей
прийшли і все було спокійно, все було мирно. На мою думку, це різниця.
Та й узагалі, тут спокійно, чисто, гарно. А на тому березі руїни.
Зате стоїть танк, стоїть сцена. Як на мене, це саме за себе каже:
показуха, не більше. Вони ж не для своїх це зробили.
Довкола все було огороджено колючим дротом.
Ви ж знаєте, що самі івангородці, громадяни РФ, у своє ж місто не можуть потрапити без спецперепустки?
Але й у Таллінні вже зрозуміли, що треба діяти, інакше можна програти Москві
в ідеологічній битві за російськомовний анклав. Знаковим стало рішення влади
наступний естонський парад перемоги у Визвольній війні провести у 2024 році у Нарві.
При цьому з 2027 року всі школи Естонії зобов'язали перейти на естонську мову навчання,
включно з нарвськими. Однак тут бракує естономовних вчителів,
і розв'язати цю проблему важко.
Тим часом у хорі "Тандем" знайшли рецепт, як полегшити дорослим мешканцям
третього за величиною міста Естонії вивчення естонської мови
та познайомити з естонською культурою. Лід розтанув завдяки музиці.
Хор "Тандем" спочатку був мовним проєктом.
Ми намагаємося прислухатися до побажань учнів.
І розмовляючи про те, як краще вчитися, вони сказали, що найчудовіше було б… співати.
Ось звідки з'явилася ідея хору.
Пілле Мафуччі викладає естонську мову на інтеграційних курсах.
Мені як естонці подобається Нарва. Вона відрізняється від решти Естонії.
Я досить швидко вивчила російську мову. Але для місцевих жителів,
на мій погляд, корисно вивчати естонську. Це дає їм більше можливостей,
дозволяє брати участь у громадському житті у всій країні.
Ансамбль "Тандем" репетирує передноворічний виступ на Петрівській площі.
Саме на цьому місці до 1993 року височив пам'ятник Леніну.
Виконавці спілкуються у процесі як естонською, так і російською.
Тим часом у Нарві багато хто продовжує орієнтуватися на російські пропагандистські ЗМІ.
Хоча їхня ретрансляція в Естонії під забороною. В основі лежить мовна та культурна проблема.
Естонія відправила на фінал конкурсу "Євробачення" у 2023 році Аліку Мілову -
уродженку Нарви, з піснею "Мости".
Так, я б сказала, що своєрідним мостом я точно себе бачу.
Тому що вийшло так, що в мене багато різних коренів - і естонських,
і українських, і російських.
Тому якось вони об'єднуються в мені воєдино.
Ось чому в моєму альбомі присутні чотири різні мови, що теж уособлює те,
що я дуже мультинаціональна людина.
Зараз Аліка живе у Таллінні. Вона є яскравим прикладом успішної інтеграції.
У Нарві я навчалася в естонській школі, завдяки чому моя естонська мова
на цей момент така чиста. Як друга рідна. За що я дуже вдячна своїм батькам.
Але саме в цій школі були якісь безглуздя, інциденти, через які у мене утворився якийсь комплекс.
Тобто, наприклад, перед естонським "Ідолом" я була досить закритою в собі людиною,
у відносинах з тими, хто говорив естонською.
Хоча моя естонська дуже добра. Але певна проблема у мене в голові була.
А на відборі на "Євробачення", ну, зрозуміло, є якісь анонімні диванні критики,
які коментували щось таке і досі іноді коментують.
Але я думаю, що якби ця проблема була більшою, ніж вона насправді є,
то я, напевно, не поїхала б цього року на "Євробачення" і не пройшла б так далеко.
Аліка - не єдина представниця нарвської молоді, яка переїхала до столиці.
Населення російськомовного містечка швидко скорочується.
З кожним роком стає приблизно на тисячу мешканців менше.
Нарві необхідно заново знайти своє місце в Естонії - замість придатка до моста "Дружба".
Потрібні нові програми та ентузіасти.
Ярославна та Вован поки що планують залишатися тут.
Ярославна з її "сірим" паспортом користується привілеями ЄС та вільним в'їздом до Росії.
Якщо вона вирішить завести дітей, вони автоматично стануть громадянами Естонії.
Митцю Вовану російська влада заборонила в'їзд до Росії на 15 років.
Але в нинішній ситуації він і сам не хотів би приїжджати.